hey what's up guys my name is Doug
sensor Martin call of duty professional
player for New York make sure you guys
check out my new show battle stations
with the Aaron Fox and Josh Hart this is
build your squad I'd say the number one
moment that stands out to me as a fan of
the NBA was when LeBron went through the
heat and he lost the Mavericks that was
probably what I've really got heavily
involved in to the NBA so guys I have
$15 in my hand over here and I'm gonna
use these 15 dollars to build a squad of
players from the last two decades
all right so here we go guys the first
person I'm gonna pick on this list of
all these players in the last 20 years
gotta go my favorite player LeBron James
we drop in five on him
we got $10 left we're gonna keep going
to heavy hitter so we have another $5
guy drop it on my boy Shaq man LeBron
and Shaq on the same team unstoppable
the reason I want the brown and Shaq is
because LeBron in my opinion is the
greatest player of all time he could do
it all and then Shaq is definitely the
best center of all time the guy is a
dominant force and having those two guys
on the same team I couldn't imagine
anybody in their primes beating them now
this is a disgrace I'm gonna take a
sleeper pick on this list which again I
don't understand it I know this is top
20 this is their primes but so far we
have LeBron Shaq in Yanis we have $4
left to spend
with this money I think the best
possible thing for me to do we got to
get another defender so I'm gonna take
$3 and put it on Kawhi Leonard we have a
two-way player arguably that's two-way
player in basketball probably gonna be
the MVP this year even though I'm a
LeBron fan so we got LeBron
we have Shaq we have Kawhi we have Yanis
and we have $1 left so with this $1 I
could pick Derrick Rose Tracy Paul
Pierce or Vince Carter I love Vince
Carter but I'm gonna take this dollar
and give it to the truth because this
guy was a killer on the Celtics so my
squad LeBron James Shaquille O'Neal
Yanis answer the kupo Paul Pierce Kawhi
Leonard God Squad let me know what you
guys think because I couldn't imagine a
better five than that if I had to give
one honorable mention I've got to give
it to Derrick man the things he did in
the playoffs
his legacy if I didn't win one
basketball game would be with Derrick
thanks for watching again this is your
boy Doug sense to Martin make sure you
guys check out my show battle stations
this airing on bleacher report this
Thursday alongside the Aaron Fox and
Josh Hart